僕は版をあるでしょ
あのインターフェイスの
あの言語日本語にスイッチしました
ええ
こちらでですねセッティングのところでですねインターフェース銀毫
タイプ v ができます日本語英語
何でもいいでしょ
でリーダーの設定で同じ空その辞書の言語をそれで設定できます
でもちろん私は数わああああインターフェイスの言語は英語
そして事象の言語も英語ですけれども今日の日本語の舞スティのためにそれを全部
を日本語に推移しました
それでまあいレッスンですねこれあら母校今私はやってるのはアラブ語ですよね
だからで
アラブ語でやっているのは例えばあの
あんじぇらーというアラブ号のあのラジオ放送ありますねそちらのポッカーストを使っ
てますそちらの podcast あのー
あれはトニー茶の女の人に頼んでプランスピットストップになってるわけですよ
あるいは youtube をですね youtube で今あの
yes no
例えば
これは今僕はスタンダーのアラブ語勉強してそれか今の
威張るラグーン tq かれバーンシリアのあラボにちょっと集中しています
だから youtube も
いっ
youtube のビデオですねそしてまあこちらであの
やはりリンクのあの輸入のですねアイコンありますよね
それ言ったん
あの持ってるとですね youtube のベージュを見ながらそちらにサブタイの頭
があればそこのアイコンに押せば食
この youtube ビデオがレッスンとして入ってきます
そしてビデオも見えるし音も聞きますし
そして
あの
#タイトル頭があのーいわゆる文字になる
なるんですよだからそちらでその言葉を言語た単語とかフレーズを勉強すできるわけ
ですよ
初稿もですねやはり
ぺー15とに見るかあのー
いわゆる文章ごとに勉強することが
できますええええええ
で今たまたまそういうその youtube のビデオ
使っていますしかし
あそれじゃなくて出したんですね生まれてが気になりません
日本語のインターフェースそれが中みたいですねそれじゃなくてレッスンの方ですね
え
例えば
まいらっしゃるんですねええ
ミニストーリー
目に家の前はに1人とはスタンダー love god は出番 d のですね
アラブ5秒後怒ってます
女子所の前にちょっと見せたかったのはですね
やはり言葉の勉強というのはですね
短期間にそのすぐ
流暢になるって事はないんですよねだから
あら後にしてもですね例えばまあ
それをいただきのそのアイコンを押せばそういう
フロアが出てきますけれども follow たんで見るとですね
やはり洗う後はね僕はん
12の2017年の12月始まったわけですよ
それにし自制が非常に熱心に勉強しましたらそれでまあそんなねシードラっと最近また
ね c なっていっていましょう
それが今があれは a
捨てる田んぼは fo 2はレスに青レスですね
どれぐらい聞いているかというのが非常にネシーナ時もあったら兄がうまたね子になっ
てきています
なぜかというとアラブ語以外にも例えばトルコぼ
トルコ語が特に住人ん
3カ月間の相手にですね非常に熱心に勉強しました
今はあまりやってませんしかしいつも
戻れますミニストーリーズを中心にやりましたからいつでもこの2ミリストーリーに
戻ってまた
リフレッシュできます
それから
例えば
なあラマニア21量がその仕事のために行く必要がありましたから
非常にこちらで集中的に勉強します
ロシアそうじゃなくて熱意ロシア語はですね
ap 5堅牢し顎
キャプチャーがおりロシア語
をし
雑魚棒
ご覧が号
ちょっと多いから
お願いしにくいんですよまあれいしゃぐ
もう
2007年から
だがか無理なが偉大だそして時々非常に集中して
だから総理もね色んな言葉を勉強している人にとってはですね時々自分のその歴史ある
位は一つだけの言葉を勉強してもですね
その1始まったけどまぁ我々いつも忘れますよ
今始まったか何ヶ月間をだかんこ号なんかはここに非常に集中的に勉強しましたけども
最近はあまりやってない
野菜もキョロパールが面白いんですよあの自分の
そのリス員がとかその
ミークアドレス歌カーとかあの
ガリー d とかエニウェイ
ええ
ああそうじゃなくてソウルんじゃなくてレっしょん
ん
そうですねぇ
小ミニストーリースキャダクト甘いレッスンですね
3 story スワールいい
ミニストーリー
ミニストーリーですがブルーのた後がないんですよ
しかしあの黄色の多分まだたくさん残ってます
すなわち
あの
このブルーからピーロートいうのはこのタブを知ってるっていうわけじゃないんですよ
それはブルーカラー黄色になったっていうのは
この単語はすでに
名器で見た事があります
それで調べて写真まだ
あの
8パーセント知らないだからそのままあのヒーローになっています
で
飛び退き指いうしたりして時の木
もう読んだりして
しかしブルーノがないんですよもうそれでも何回も中も読みます
聞きます
by に行ってるんですねー
ん
まあどこがほとんど茶の ipad
あるしますけれども play コース r 用とありますよね
それは非常に便利なんですよ特に ios ipad 場合はそれ音声バー
その60のミニストーリーがありますからこれは一日中
車のな母
一応このストーリー聞けますよそれ例えば a story 20番目から30番目た
箇所選べられますけれどもいつも着ることができます
それは非常にあの
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
そうですねあとはまあ普通に良い皆と同じように知らない単語ズフレイるーばによって
フレーズぞ
セーブして保存してリビューします
しかしば分僕の時間のそうですね
7枚くらいはピッグだけなんですよ
なぜかというと非常にやりやすいんですよどこでもできます
書士聞いて分からないからええ
じゃあもうひどそのストーリーを開いてみてえええ
これはん
前に何回も読んだことがありますけれどもそれでも分かっ
それでもう一度よあげましょう
で
毎回聞いて毎回読んでですね
どこかこの前気がつかなかったところがあるわけですよ
少しずつ少しずつが慣れてきます
そうですねで僕はの戦略としてはこういうイージーなミニストーリーから難しい
youtube
4輪キャスター
車両部をやりますよねその簡単なミニ stories あ
時々彼の名はな自分を繰り返し繰り返して意味がないっていうか面白くない
お越しろこないけれども頭を訓練するためにですね
私その言語に慣れるためにいますね非常に役に立ちます
しかし
あのっ
生まれつまらないそしてじゃあ面白い
その youtube とか通ってから作っていきます少しじっくり難しい難しいから
思いつかれましたじゃあまたやりやすい優しい
その両方いつもこの
少しずつ呂やりますあの
あらボロ場合はたくさんの内容がないからある
英語の場合は中間くらいの内容が結構たくさんあります
あのロシアゴムそうですけれどもだから初心者のもの
中ぐらいのは難しいものいろいろあります
あるから場合は処理がないですこの場合はやはり民主党リスト
うんとに難しいものしかないんですよ
やはりインポート機能というのはインポートのまあ
ブラウズリーステンション日本語でどう言いますか知りませんけども
それが
一旦あるとですねやはりこれをクリックすればどこの新聞とこの youtube
ビデオでもすべてその食導入できました日本ています
ネットこれがインポートキーなので入っ
私は一つはか7巻があったら見るようにしかとわかる単語があっ
こうやってすぐに
チェックマークつけるようにしてますそうですねはい
ミニアプリ樹君の投資の名前はどうしますか
それはお子の名前は
バズにする時までして a めんどくさいからその飛ばしてセキュアにがあー
ok
大体の時は無視してます無視しています
はい
ただ何か重要な年だなって思うときは
そのまま無視しないでそうですね
そしてあのキーボードで s ということも
x 使っ
あーなるほど分
知ってる単語だったら経緯喉
入らないと
鳥キャシーというか x だから都市の名前
さあ自分のそのしてる単語のに数えないために無視してるんですよね
一つはもう猫
あと女子顎の方は
まず猫の絵ちゃっててバインポーズというの方
はい
ちょっと前ですからね ok
ポンポン in ポーズ知ってるしていらっしゃいますか
この意味
文を見ればわかりますけど市看護一単語でなんだっていうレッドちょっとまあ
時があるああの僕もの場合はねぇ例えば in ポーズというのは生んだ
まあその全然知らないというわけじゃないけども一つアイディアがあるっていうかね
僕の場合はねその時に state です1から2に
進展します
前にはでねあーなるほどはいこういうこと言えるコア
まあですね自分のページが明るくなるのがですねひとつの私は神としているという
なるほどですから
だからまあまあはっきりやっぱーせんたー
あのしっかりしてないけれどもまぁだいたいわかるというのがニートが32だんだん
あの
進呈しますなるほどで
逆 new 全然わから同じ単語ますその後馬が分からなくなる時もありますからまた
位置に戻っ戻してもいいんですよだけど目4的に前へ前へ進みたいですよ
だから民主通りでも湧かなくても次へ次へと
そして言葉もそのまあ
8パーセント獅子花井にしても223にマニュはに入り戻ってビーチ
で苦しいお分かりますか分からないです
ok
でそんな感じでやってますファイアーレプロセキュリティーチャージとカーソルバー
zoom air
そして saa 簿の場合はですねその文章
文章ごとに勉強してますかそれとももう全然ペー子っていうジョインページで勉強
するっぽい
年分で
全文ですねはい
はいっ
で貯金のページへ行く時にですねその日ビューしますかそれとも別に理由しないです
からあの
単語リッパーレビューしません島瀬全く終わったあと全部終わったデビューしますああ
そうですか
ok
そんな感じですねわかりましたねー
ロシア語の方は入っ
ネッテラー
はいっ
ちょっと待ってください
うん
aimi に英語でせまだ
英語ですかあせません
青系
に stories ウォ
えっとこれ1文1文
この左側のあれは
厚約この左側ですね
あるでしょ左側入っ
その一番ショックレスあ私いつもこうして
はいえーあの翻訳機能が翻訳あるのでこれよりをしてなるほど
勉強していますでこのオーディオのシンボルを4バーどうなりました
ん
おいでイイですかえっ
はいつも
ここをして
入ってますね
れ出てくるのはそれがいわゆるテックスピッチすかそれとも自然の恋使う
自然の声っていうかこのついける
この付属しているよと言うとそうですね僕はモブ同じ編み方ですね
[音楽]
やってますロシア語の場合はページから次のページ時にレビューしますかそれとも同じ
ような
終わってから夫からやレビューしてもう1回
読み直すって感じですなるほど
でそれを何回も
それをベースにアレイしますかはいえっと全部あのダウンロードして
あの itunes の方に入れてます
感想ですかはいしっ
阿南さんとしていきとを得るあと3人か知りませんけども
何か質問あります辛く長いさ聞きたい
ありますけど
えっ右下折図から始めるかスエットミニストーリーして多分
beginner to
だと思うんですよねだか日にナンバーワンの教材をやりますか
最初に
いや僕は
前は値引きいわゆる
ビギナーのた日初心者のための本を買ってですねはい出来
背中部のその
右手刀日は必ずしもビギナーのなよよりは難しくない
というのはそういうまったくべきなのためのおい本なんかはですね
じゃあ何の優しいか例えば a
お父さんお母さんおじいさんそういう家族の名前だとかいろいろな前田とからそれ
優しい辛そう
必ずしもそうじゃないんですよ
ねそしていいまた彼の初心者の本でもあぁこれは硬さ
方さあのお父さんお母さんそして
七海さんぽうよ紹介しましょうどこ族の家族ですね
面白くないし自然的でもないし優しくないわけですよ
だからミニストーリーはですねこの繰り返しが多いから
ね普通の写真者のやつはですね ok
その1/その2/そのさ沢山の繰り返しかないんですそれミーティ通りの場合はその1
回その
その七実様の2階
ブーバしたとかあその努力ゼロスねえっ何
1はれ主は行きました
七海さんは本や車できましたか
2件お家さんじゃなくていいわけですよ
そしてその場合は質問の形
ネガティブの形そして同じ単語くる回数
繰り返されるわけですよだから僕にとっては右 stories は普通のあの初心者
6型もその際秒祈りも
ます
やりやすいそしてっ
くりか同じストーリーの中も繰り返し
そして
日本はあのような事情は知らないけども
英語いわゆる母国語が英語の人たちのためにはですね
いつも同じその
いわゆるオーディオにはですね英語が入ってくるわけでしょ
this story about ななみー fendi
ok ok 最初それ姫トランスっ子今度はねそんな事故のないを聞くときにいつも
同じ英語聞かないといけます
立はに摘んだから右 stories はもういわゆる目的
言語しかないですねロシア語ならロシア語やログなら
んそれはそいつはだからその場合は僕は
さん次回も聞けますその続けて続けで3時間じゃなくて
12345また123456712345678区
しかし最終的には同じなようモス
30回も聴いてますよ見ます
まあ実感を呼びます
頭脳がね脳が慣れてきます
だからどこが実にストレスが最初からでも日で僕はアナボードが停車後
グリー守護隅にストーリー始まった時ばですね
おとうでしょ意味は何もないんですよもちろん何もない
今多分723がロシア語荒いですよはい応答だけですよ
土木があどこが単語をテュフ式に
3カ月間だったら何回も何回も聞いてもう読んで調べて調べて犬にあの見てまた忘れて
また調べてまた忘れて
近し3カ月間立つとですね少しずつ
を頭が意味だ
脳が no 金必ずその脳の役割というのは
パターンを作るんですよ脳がその説明がなくてもですね
そのルーラーこれはそうどこそこのにそれは説明がなくて目のなっても脳がそのやはり
脳がパターンを
を作る機能の機会ですよそ嚢がいい
で奏しずつもちろんそこでちょっと
音でぶーその分防止ラヴィタ1カットどうしてこうなるかと
調べるのもいいんですけれども
ロシア語のまいますね例えばしかしその
ぽんぽ的説明に対して自分はそういう経験がないと説明が何の意味もないんです
それがロシア語でこのこういう変会がありますというのが自分がそれが
経験があると
その時に説明が通じるんですよ
だからたくさん聞いてたくさん謎
わからない通して生じる抗議しがある
調べたらあーなるほど
だけでもどんどん初めてその
今基本の文法勉強するその基本が出来たらそれから話できるそうじゃないんです
ねだからそういう意味では実に stories が非常にそれのあの子んですよ
耐寒訓練訓練訓練を発揮かめり所の進んだ難しいな用意やってもまた実に1人にいつで
も
もどって来る geebee
ジムで7日本語でどう言いますかこう言ってあるでしょ
そんなお腹その高はでしょ怖いこれは3リストはです
初心者にとってもいいしそして後の佐野いわゆるコア働く人ってにょ美的品の同市基本
の構造
全部見る
的にあるから
皆さんをすべてのミニストリー菅さん次回もよ次回も聞いて脳がそれに慣れてきた時点
で非常に良い
机上でしょ
だから僕はミニストリー数ができてからええ
やはり話できる速くなっている僕はロシア語始まった時1年も誰ともう話だ
者が利いただけ
母ちゃん聞きましたーくさん4
でチェここでももう半年もかかりました
今はトルコ帽ペルシャ語あら後3ヶ月間
以内に今人と話しできできるという
右ストーリーズのミニストーリーの欠陥ですっ
アーマー分
プレイヤー脳が慣れてくる
voodoo
しかし
なぁいや版つまらないといえば相撲だけでも30回目同じミニストーリーを聞いても
いつも前に来な気がつかなかった部分
気がつくわけでしょ楮
まあロシア語で遊泳型とか何か火がつくわけでしょ
しかしん
今の時点で新盆のミニストーリー goo
そうですね理事分も聞いたらもうもう
まあまあ止めます
しかし最初の間は非常に高貴寺があるから
何回か聴いてもいいんですよん
[音楽]
他に何か質問ありますかありません
おってまあそういうところでどうも本当に息をのない3 d 3回していっ
いただいてありがとうございます人
頑張ってくださいこちらこそありがとうございますこの機会を
じゃそれありがとうございました
[音楽]
ん